so I had a brief moment where I was
really excited for seeing sabotage it
has Arnold Schwarzenegger in it I love
that guy it's directed by David Ayer he
made training day and end of watch and
then I found out who it was written by
then all of a sudden I was basically the
Terminator in t2 when they turned him
off for the night sabotage is directed
by David Ayer and stars Arnold
Schwarzenegger Sam Worthington Terrence
Howard Olivia Williams and some other
people as well with movies about
essentially some DEA agents and their
undercover and they attempt to steal
some money from something and we watched
this happen in the opening scene it goes
wrong then an investigation happens
amongst their crew and then people are
after them because they're afraid that
their money was stolen and that to
figure out who took the money where the
money went did they take the money did
someone else take the money where's the
money and Arnold Schwarzenegger is
awesome like I said in my intro I was
excited about this movie until I found
out who the writer was and that writer
is skip woods a man behind such films
like x-men origins a good day to die
hard a good day to die for everyone who
saw it and this movie is filled with his
type of writing it's completely
convoluted a lot of it doesn't make
sense it doesn't seem to go anywhere I'm
not the kind of guy who goes to movie
and goes that movie was too violent I
did not like that film it was violent
and disgusting and I do not approve of
this in my children will never lay eyes
on such entertainment ever I'm not that
guy at all one of my all-time favorite
movies is 7 which is terrifically
disgusting but the problem I think I
have a sabotage is depiction of violence
is that it seems to glorify it lots of
innocent bystanders are killed civilians
and it's very bloody and very disgusting
and they linger on if they show it as if
it's almost like a video game where you
can run around and just smash up society
there's a lot of scenes like that in
this film where violence is shown and it
doesn't really need to be shown and I
understand they're going for a realism
that may be there but when you use a
whole bunch of over exaggerated CGI
blood there is no realism to it it's
just gratuitous and I don't feel like
the violence in the movie is really
justified because even though they are
showing people who are trying to do the
right
the problem is none of the characters in
the film that are supposed to be the
good guys are actually likable in any
way none of them in fact I pretty much
hated almost every character in this
movie except for Arnold Schwarzenegger
his character who seems to be the only
one in this film who has even a shred of
integrity him and Olivia Williams
character who is another police officer
who's investigating the DEA agents the
characters in this film are not only
vastly unlikable but you don't know a
thing about any of them except for
Arnold character everyone in this film
particularly this girl named Lizzy who
is the most unlikable unwatchable
character I've seen in movies in many
years she is such a repulsive character
and none of these people are likable at
all but I think of awesome DEA agents I
think of Hank Schrader from Breaking Bad
I do not think of a whole bunch of
people who go in a strip club badger a
whole bunch of women and then beat up
the security guards at the strip club
the violence in the film is so
exaggerated to the point where civilians
are getting their bodies exploded and
stuff and it's just crazy actually how
unnecessarily violent this movie is that
being said there is an extreme plus to
this movie and that is Arnold because
I'm not just an Arnold Schwarzenegger
fan I like to see him walk around and
say funny lines and smoke cigars because
he does that in this film this is
actually a very dark performance for him
and it actually has a lot of nuances to
it it's probably his best performance
after his governor term once you figure
out where it's going it doesn't make any
sense and there's a large portion in the
middle that is so boring where nothing
happens and it's just a whole bunch of
investigating a whole bunch of body
parts this is probably Arnold's most
violent film even though movies like
commando are really violent those movies
weren't taken seriously this movie takes
it very seriously when people are
exploding and you're finding spleens and
intestines everywhere they were trying
to sell realism by David Ayer's very
hardcore filming style but the realism
was replaced with this extremely
over-the-top grotesque violence that
didn't make sense the characters were
incredibly unlikable the story didn't
make any sense but Arnold is the one
saving grace to the film and the one
thing that kept me interested in where
it was going so I will give sabotage a
c-minus it's not a terrible film but I
can tell you that I never really want to
see it again because of the incredibly
unlikable
characters and the unnecessary grotesque
just flying everywhere so guys if
you did see sabotage let me know what
you thought of it and as always guys
thank you so much for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck nice